vous présente maintenant les principales
fraude dont sont victimes les canadiens
par groupe d'âge tels que compilés par
le centre antifraude du canada chez les
10 29 ans en troisième position des
marchandises
vous voyez sur les réseaux sociaux de la
publicité pour des produits qui sont
chères normalement et qui leur sont
offerts à prix réduit ça vous mène vers
un site entièrement faux qui prend votre
argent et qui ne vous livre rien numéro
2 les offres d'emploi frauduleuses
regardez le nombre d'entreprises qui
vous met en garde sur des sites d'offres
d'emploi
vous remarquez une offre de télétravail
par une entreprise connue l'entreprise
qui n'est pas la vraie évidemment vous
envoie un chèque et vous demande
d'acheter ce qu'il faut pour la
formation et de l'équipement
informatique
quelques jours plus tard vous avez
acheté tout ça vous découvrez que le
chèque est sans provision
vous aviez déjà payé pour le matériel
qui lui ne viendra jamais et numéro 1
un grand classique l'hameçonnage le
texto du gouvernement la banque qui vous
annoncent un remboursement une première
prestation qui vous demande de cliquer
ici
rentrez vos renseignements votre nip et
voilà vous venez de mordre à l'hameçon
chez les 30 59 ans maintenant un groupe
d'âge plus riches donc des fraudes plus
importante en troisième place
les offres des services frauduleuses
dont on vous a déjà parlé on vous
appelle pour vous annoncer que votre
ordinateur un virus par exemple disent
avoir fait des choses mais dans le fond
lui rien qui y oppose logiciel latin
dans l'fond et en charge est vraiment
pris la deuxième position
le stratagème de romance la personne
avec qui vous aviez une belle complicité
sur facebook ou tender mais que vous
n'aviez pas encore rencontré a
soudainement de gros problèmes et vous
demande de lui transférer de l'argent
première position
l'extorsion
on vous a déjà parlé de la fraude de l'
agence du revenu et bien le scénario un
peu évolué c'est toujours un supposé
agents du gouvernement qui vous appelle
mais cette fois parce que votre numéro
d'assurance sociale resservi dans une
fraude et là on vous dit qu'il faut
crans ferrer votre argent en lieu sûr et
qu'il faut collaborer
sinon vous serez poursuivis pour
implication dans la fronde beaucoup
d'immigrants sont victimes de ça je vais
vous expliquer qu on vous donne 45
minutes
ces vingt mille je suis des migrants des
pays communistes respect mr la police
les plus de 60 ans maintenant sont
victimes des mêmes fraudes que les 30 59
dans les premières positions mais cela
s'ajoute l'enquète bancaire écoutez bien
ça un scooter vous appelle sur votre
ligne résidentielle et se présente comme
un employé de la banque qui veut
vérifier vos données rassurez vous tout
de suite par mesure de sécurité on va
vous demander de raccrocher et de
rappeler aux numéros inscrits à l'endos
de votre carte de crédit
c'est ce qu'on va vous dire au téléphone
donc aller chercher votre carte monsieur
là vous l'avez hockey raccrocher et
appelé ce que bien des gens ne savent
pas c'est que si votre interlocuteur ne
raccroche pas avec une ligne
résidentielle
vous restez connectés pendant au moins
trente secondes alors quand vous
reprenez le téléphone et que vous
composez les fraudeurs est toujours à
l'autre bout du fil et peut même vous
faire entendre
une fausse tonalité alors là vous pensez
vraiment chez visa et mastercard et vous
répondez à toutes ces questions
donc quand on vous demande d'appeler
quelque part attendez donc cinq minutes
avant de le faire sachez aussi qu'on
signale en ce moment un nombre élevé de
fraudes dans le domaine du bois de
chauffage des animaux domestiques et
découvre le visage effet vous